(camera clicking)
- [Female Narrator] The
Secret Service is more
than black sunglasses, ear
pieces, and two-piece suits.
- [Male Narrator] They're
also an elite team
of investigators solving some
of the nation's biggest crimes.
- [Female Narrator]
Sometimes, using nothing more
than a blot of ink.
Here we are: the lobby
of the Secret Service.
- [Male Narrator] There were the only
authorized shots we could get.
- [Female Narrator] Upstairs, in the lab,
we got to see all the high-tech machines
analysts use in forensic investigations.
They have names with things
like 8,000 after them
so you know they're complicated.
- [Male Narrator] Did you film a printer?
- [Female Narrator] I did.
- [Male Narrator] The lab
includes people like Trista,
who specializes in handwriting analysis
to investigate threat
letters or ransom notes.
Jeffrey investigates
fraudulent items like IDs,
traveler's checks, credit cards.
- [Female Narrator] And Irina,
she works in the
International Ink Library.
- My name is Irina Geiman.
I am a document analyst with
the United States Secret Service.
The Secret Service has the
largest ink library in the world.
There are over 12,000 inks
that are currently in the collection.
- [Female Narrator] This includes pens,
bottled ink, and printer cartridges.
- [Male Narrator] Basically,
this team of scientists
is using ink to help solve crimes.
- [Female Narrator]
They're ink-vestigators.
- [Male Narrator] Unh-uh,
no, don't do that.
- [Female Narrator] OK,
so here's an example.
Someone writes a threatening
letter to the President.
- [Male Narrator] Irina
will sample that ink
and then compare it to her collection.
- [Female Narrator] Exactly,
she can figure out what kind
of ink was used, and, hopefully,
it helps solve the case.
Here's another ink-xample.
- [Male Narrator] Nope, gimme that script.
- The most counterfeited bank note
within the United States is $20,
and it's printed with inkjet, which means
somebody takes their very
simple at-home printer
and decides to print money.
- [Male Narrator] Irina can
compare the counterfeit currency
to any printers found at
the scene of the crime
and help make a match.
- [Female Narrator] OK,
time for a little science.
- [Male Narrator] Here's
why you need 12,000 samples
of, let's be honest, mostly black ink.
- [Irina] A lot of the black
inks are not just black.
They're actually a collection
of different color components.
There could be blues
then reds and yellows,
and maybe a little bit of green.
- [Female Narrator] Irina can,
for lack of a better term,
sequence black ink like you would DNA,
and find the exact breakdown of color.
- [Male Narrator] That's
how she can make a match.
- So what appears black at a first glance
is actually extremely
different on the inside,
and it's really fun, as a chemist,
to be able to take the ink
apart and see how it's made.
I'm a nerd at heart. (laughs)
I love the chemistry of it.
I love the mystery of solving a case.
I just really love what I do,
so it may not look
exactly like it's on TV,
but it's really fun to be in an lab
and to be able to do the analysis
and to be able to help and assist all
the law enforcement agencies
that I work with daily.
- [Female Narrator] So, Irina,
can you give us any more examples?
- It's on a need to know basis,
and you do not need to know.
- [Male Narrator] Well, it looks like
this case is all dried up.
(bright music)